guys how you doing today
i haven't i haven't seen uh that parking
place i could i can see glenn's being a
bad [ __ ] yeah
i hate that [ __ ] piss me off now let me
let me let me is there because everybody
can park closer to the column
you got to get your job for the listener
at home you couldn't find a parking spot
in the garage in the basement we're in a
we're in a building editing and the
basement has some spots if you're going
to take an end spot
you got to park as close to the column
as you possibly can
so that the middle guy doesn't have to
park too close to the other end
because then you show up and there's
either two cars that are parked too too
far from like this three there's three
spots right
two two cars parked in the column and
then one in the cent wedged in the
center okay now if both people don't
park close to the column then there's no
spot in the center you can't get in
there unless you're driving a [ __ ]
smart car or a motorcycle
right so there were no parking spots
that i could get into that didn't
require me
you know either being uh you know
opening my door into a column or
no now we know i know glenn well enough
as do you that there are certain times
that glenn comes in hot
and it's a fun thing that we can all
joke around about because we can turn it
into an episode or something like that
for example the serial eating defense
which we'll get into later that's the
best example and then there are
sometimes
not just glenn probably each and every
one of us that we come in hot and we
realize let's not joke about that
let's just move on from it because i
think i i think it might make him more
upset but not in a funny way well
yeah well it would make me upset if you
guys disagreed
well i don't disagree that's that the
thing is i can get my [ __ ] car right
up next to that column right up next to
it i mean like so close that most people
would be nervous because i know how to
drive
park
closer to the column when you park your
car think about other people
here's another thing that bugs me
this morning and i backed my car in yeah
and i tried to get it super close to the
call backing it in you can actually get
it closer to the column because you can
it's harder you can't see the
you can't see the side of the car as
well uh
when you're going forward but when
you're going backwards you can see the
side of the car in the rear view in the
side mirror
so you can get like crazy [ __ ] close
to the column with that side mirror
see any closer to the column now i was
thinking about this when i was back in
it i was actually thinking i should get
pretty close to that column so there's
room in the space next to me it crossed
my mind but in my mind i was like okay
i'm pretty damn close any closer would
be would be reckless
yeah i don't know i'd have to take a
closer look to it but when when when i
park it in when i park it close to the
call because it's the same thing in
defense by the way i said we
the podcast i think we should go down
there and take a look measure
guys
[Music]
wow listener
okay
we've got a lot to talk about all right
we went down to the garage uh to the
parking garage to investigate the
situation and uh pick up some data
points um you know and uh charlie do you
want to defend yourself oh yeah oh yeah
not only am i reasonably parked and i
think rob will back me up
um i'm beyond reasonably parked to the
point where i was overly cautious
that you know there's two white
guidelines that you're supposed to park
your car in between not only am i over
the white line as close to the pole and
your argument is i could even get
further past that white line and even
closer
but i am more
close to the pole than i am the other
line on the other side of the car so we
measured about 16 inches from the pole
which is too far for you
and and
so about 25 inches from the next
line and then there's the beyond that
line there's the next parking spot so
i probably could have gotten closer to
the pole but to me like my car starts
beeping at about 13 inches you also
don't need you also don't need to those
particular spots are a little bit wider
than the other spots so where you got
which also comparatively speaking you
you you did park closer to the pole than
everyone except for one other guy who
got
uh what what did we that guy got that
guy got 10 inches from the pole was it
10 10 10
10.
oh that or or a lady let's be fair yeah
yeah yeah yeah
courteous than that yeah there's a yeah
a very strong possibility that that's a
lady the question is um are what what
are we assuming are the basic guidelines
and or laws of parking for example to
charlie's point isn't it generally
assumed that those lines because you
said something very interesting and
telling charlie said i'm over the line
on one side meaning i'm too close to one
line i'm over one line and too far away
from the other line thus proving that
i've parked as close to the pole as i
could and you said those lines don't
mean anything
except that they don't mean this seems
like chaos to me no no when you're
dealing with compact spots now by the
way you know for listeners who don't
live in los angeles or
or new york or some large metropolitan
city where parking is just not an issue
you guys probably don't even know what
the [ __ ] we're talking about right
because there's plenty of parking where
you live
uh and that's great for you but in los
angeles uh people who designed
parkinson's really the latest of you man
to think that that parking problems
aren't a problem for everyone man
they're not uh i'm from montgomery
alabama you can you
yeah just park in the field and you're
good to go yeah it's great um
but in in los angeles they love to
design parking garages where uh the vast
majority of the spots are for quote
compact cars i don't know what they're
thinking because most cars are not
compact so to me they're just getting
greedy and trying to create as many
parking spots as they possibly can
that's where the whole like line thing
is kind of like well okay i know these
are super small spots so regardless of
where the line is i gotta park as far
over as i possibly can to make room for
the other cars that's it that's it
well
okay so another interesting nobody's
nobody's coming down there giving you a
ticket because you parked a little over
the line you know what i'm sorry yeah uh
another interesting thing well i will
say when i parked this morning i parked
i thought you know what i'm going to try
to get close that pole
make a little room on the other side
which is what you're hoping for it's
what you're getting angry about you're
thinking that people aren't considering
that yes yeah and
and on top of that i i being like i when
i got out of my car i was like yeah
that's about as close to the polls i
feel comfortable getting in and out of
but
my car's small
and i and i don't i
a don't really worry so much about the
lines but i mean about parking but i be
don't care so much about the way other
people park no and so yeah it's an
obsession of mine if it's an obsession
of yours
i would suggest getting a smaller car
yeah because okay in terms of justice
for uh i would say that you are parked
directly next to somebody who has like a
hunt like a honda right i think it was a
very small car yeah maybe
now
let's just say theoretically that person
wasn't parked as close to the poles you
would have liked them to couldn't they
just as easily turn around to you and
say
hey i purposefully picked a car
that is actually a drivable and livable
car for the city of los angeles because
it's so [ __ ] packed here right you
chose a car that's twice as big as
everybody else's car but you don't know
why i chose that car you don't know why
i need that car okay but but you don't
know that somebody willfully like to
charlie's point who he just said he
actually did try to park as close as he
felt comfortable to the pole yeah
meaning like this was not something that
slipped his mind or he just didn't give
a [ __ ] he did his best
he did his best i don't really did his
best but he but he definitely considered
it he definitely considered it and i do
appreciate that
i can also understand getting frustrated
when somebody's accusing you of not
doing something that you specifically
actually tried so you know i gotta say
you look at your car and it's over the
lines on both sides even when it's
perfect because it's a compact spot
because every spot in that garage is a
compact spot and not everybody has a
compact car my car's you know my car's
not that big that's big you're not
driving around in a ram truck you know
but what if i did what if i had a ford
f-150 because i'm hauling [ __ ] around
all the time i couldn't even park in the
garage no you couldn't and then you
you'd have to take that into
consideration before you got frustrated
you'd be like okay i've made the choice
to get something that is not gonna fit
anywhere no if you were living in
montgomery alabama it wouldn't be an
issue but you live in a major major
jam-packed full metropolitan area yeah
so maybe every once in a while you're
going to run into issues where parking
is a problem i can't the thing is like i
can't fit my two kids
uh all their soccer buddies and their
friends from school and my dogs all in a
car if it's small i just can't you know
i mean like i don't i don't want to
drive an suv i don't i'd rather drive a
smaller car but i can't i i mean it's
not practical for me for my lifestyle
all the problems with the with the
climate why are you having so many
children glenn i only have two kids
that's a that's a lot of children what
about dog methane aren't dogs getting
off
dogs are off gassing like crazy i think
you're thinking about cows by the way by
the way i rescued my dogs so i didn't
breed my dogs i didn't you know what i'm
saying i rescued them did you rescue you
were they drowning
huh did you rescue did you adopt your
children
they rescued them from uh all right so
what we've learned is that
unfortunately we settled the dispute
without a ton of fireworks and that's
why we've lasted as long as we have but
the characters in this episode do have a
ton of fireworks and that's where the
comedy comes from segway let's talk
about this we're talking about mac bangs
dennis's mom yeah i love this one i did
too i really enjoyed it
this is the first episode you in a
episode that you and i wrote together
for clarity's sake we would always sort
of sit down and outline the things
together the three of us and then we
would say all right someone goes off
done draft and rob would take a draft
draft we'd do it together and this was
the first one that you and i went off on
and uh i i
feel like you know we had some success
with this one yeah absolutely definitely
i mean and it's not as if you know again
like charlie said like we're all very
involved in the uh
and the conceiving of the story and the
breaking of the story and the outlining
of the story so it's not as if we came
up with it you know no no no whole cloth
is that the saying
yes
uh but uh
but i was pretty proud of our execution
and um and we and we created the
character of max mom which i'm also very
proud of a lot a lot of firsts in this
one charlie work from the first time
that came up and right sort of we just
took the character in that direction
after that moment yeah you you you had a
you had a so my one of my wife's
favorite moments in the entire show is
in this episode and it's you charlie
it's after
frank leaves you in charge in that back
office and he walks out and you're like
yeah no i got it i got he's like you
know he walks out you sit down on the
desk you pick up the calculator you look
at the calculator and you're like
what are
you yeah and that is and that's one of
jill's favorite moments and that kind of
thing sort of became where we took your
character that's right direction we took
that level of stupidity
not knowing what account got locked in
there yeah and that was just an improv
that wasn't in the script that was just
something you did
yeah and that was uh it was very funny
um seeing off the set a lot in this
episode oh really so many times
literally looking directly up into
lights come on when you when you come
into these
i noticed in one of the other episodes
we one like a few uh episodes ago
but um how about this when mary
elizabeth when the waitress walks into
the bar at the in the final scene the
the first time she opens the door and we
look out and there's a brick wall yeah
yeah yeah that's then it cuts to us then
it cuts back to her and it's just gone
what
what was happening there what i don't
know wasn't there anybody who was in a
position to say hey you young kids let's
let's let's get something yeah there
were a lot of people in that position
and they didn't do it no
um not sure what happened there let's
blame someone else um
yeah uh well i took a bunch of notes and
you took some notes i can't i can't read
a single one oh boy i was putting on
some big frank reynolds
should have had those glasses on when
you parked
oh
[ __ ]
do you need parking glasses do you need
parking glasses maybe you guys should
put some glasses on when you buy cars
yeah yeah yeah sorry yeah yeah yeah
i'm going back i'm not
i've already decided i was just yeah
you're just doing a joke it's kind of
joke but but now at home thinks
let me say for the record charlie you
did not park that badly thank you you
really didn't i would argue you could
have gotten closer but i appreciate that
you tried and you did get pretty close
considering you know what i mean and
also those spots don't require it as
much those are like two of the biggest
spots
even more i can't believe we're talking
about this here's what i'll do i'll if i
get to the off the place early in the
morning i'll get close as [ __ ] to that
that pole and then i'll see if there's a
cone around i'll pop a cone in the spot
i'll save it for you oh [ __ ] but well i
was going to have ross i was going to
have ross put my name on a spot that's
what i'm going to do guys i can't read
any of my well do you know sean levy's
got a spot down there yeah in this
building yeah because the the right next
door they're doing a netflix he's got
the best spot he's got the best spot
right so i texted him and i said
i said this is a phantom spot isn't it
and then he wrote back i'm in new york
are you coming back anytime soon no it's
a fandom spot we should take that we
should take that spot there's never
anybody in there so yeah that's that's
not uh waiting for sean to come he's not
going to come no
no why would he he's got he's got other
things to do than to be at this uh
random building in studio city i used to
park in vin diesel's spot
when i went to go to jason bateman's
office because he had a spot there and i
was like he ain't coming in here so i
just parked in a spot every day but it
would be really interesting if he didn't
[ __ ] parked the bus
that's pretty good man that was pretty
good you got to be [ __ ] kidding me
um
what else do we have uh i can't read my
notes
just for the listener at home generally
just staring at this piece of paper
uh this is my last time writing notes
i'm not doing it again can i see if i
can find no no no let me see if i can
say i don't know if i know your hand
right i know your hand it is on a cr
like a cranium uh from
the board game yeah i don't know how i
have this but i did that's that is
[ __ ] hilarious oh first time we shot
in guigino's is this correct the the the
lunch date that danny goes on no what
other scene do we have use it in uh gun
fever uh
date with uh
sweet d but i love that scene and then
danny's daughter comes over and he leers
at her which was all very strange
yeah that's lucy devito playing the uh
the waitress that he ogles but if you
don't know it's lucy then it's not that
strange but we wanted to give lucy apart
and we only had that one left and we
said all right you want to do this yeah
oh oh so the song okay so so we're on
set that day
uh in the scene where
frank and matt go to the disco tech to
meet some ladies this is the best and
what is in the script is that he's got a
move like a very specific move that he's
dancing to and then we're doing the
scene and at one point
this is not scripted he goes back onto
the dance floor and he says hey ladies
i'm frank remember and then he goes go
he starts doing the movement he starts
doing the move and singing go for it
go for it what the [ __ ] is he doing we
have no idea what he's doing why saying
that or whatever because there's no
music that's actually playing no
and then in post we thought it was so
funny but we were like what if we
wrote and recorded a song that we sung
yeah that he and that's actually us
that's that's that's me singing and
that's you and i yeah you and i so what
happens when we found the disco song
right oh this disco song works really
fun for this scene
and then when we were posting it we were
like i wouldn't be funny if he was
singing along to the thing and yeah and
we sort of riffed on it i was very
jealous that
when we went to go do the recording of
that i was i had left for my honeymoon
yeah i knew there must have been a
reason why you weren't on that track i
wasn't honest that's why it's you two
guys yeah it always bums me out because
i would like to
go for it as well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well here's a question for you guys have
you ever banged somebody's mom
yeah well yeah yeah
sure i mean so if some of you yeah
my
that's not what i mean though oh uh what
i mean is have you ever banged did you
ever bang a friend's mom
no of course not no did you no no
no
no i wouldn't have wanted to there
weren't there weren't any that that i
wanted to you know i would say they
wouldn't have wanted to when it came to
to me
yeah they they probably wouldn't wanted
to with me either but i i didn't want to
with them yeah we are starting to get to
that age though where our children will
be you know like in like six or seven
years they will be like of the age where
they're starting to have sex
and then i as we all remember like late
late in high school um
and
and then we would you know be around
other people's parents but you never
thought of them as sexual objects in any
way shape
but um do you think that your children's
um do you think that your children's
friends are going to want to have sex
with jill
i think so biologically sure yeah yeah
sure that kid like the little teenage
boys are so horny yeah but i don't
remember ever feeling that way about any
of my friend's mother well because you
didn't grow up in los angeles where eat
fair yeah i mean
women
look
well i'm not gonna people i don't
suggest humans
i don't know what you're talking about i
don't either i don't know people looking
great beautiful everywhere
who was that person that just came in
and started you know started talking
right on my mic it was [ __ ] spielberg
okay guys
that was fun you got me stupid can you
talk about parking a little bit in the
city because i
i haven't parked the car in 30 years
yeah you think i parked my own car and i
have a car well i know i have a fleet of
car exactly i just don't drive him and i
certainly don't park him what the hell
are you talking about man come on come
on come on
what are you talking about is that
are you saying i'm doing a bad
impression to myself what are you saying
what are you saying
i'm sorry okay yeah it's a weird thing
to say anyway uh but if i did park my
car i'd like to think that i
could park it pretty close to the column
oh charlie you gotta say
yeah
well thank you steven that was so good
thank you thanks for popping your head
and you know make an even greater effort
next time
steven is uh editing his uh most recent
movie in the same place as us and so we
just kind of hang out and he pops in and
every now and then and so it's always
good to see him i like him he's a good
guy yeah he's great yeah
do you think uh what do you think the
chances are
he's ever seen
a s not an episode but a scene from it's
always sunny i think they're pretty high
yeah i mean he strikes me as the kind of
guy who likes to know what's out there
and certainly what people are seeing i
think if a show has been on for 15 years
most people are going to be like let me
just at least pop it in like why does
everybody like this show and then you
know and then they'll be confused
as to why anyone does unless they go
back and again and again and again and
then maybe they get it
but probably not
you know
i bet i bet not i bet i bet no no no you
you don't think he's seen it no no i
don't want to ask him because i don't
want to
not even the scene
so he doesn't even know who we are and
he's popping his head in there no he
just likes podcasts
he does every reputation is really
enjoying podcasts that's true three guys
just talking just talking and talking
yeah yeah yeah
that's high entertainment that's high
art
yeah yeah
um what else guys
what else what else do you guys remember
from that episode what uh should we talk
about sandy martin should we talk about
her amazing performance as a max mom yep
uh and obviously we shot that in philly
so we we flew both both uh sandy and um
lynn marie wait is this the first time
we met let me know because she was in
the molestation episode oh right of
course
i think it was i really enjoyed the uh
the
the uh what's the word that the contrast
between me being like skeevy with her
and her just being like super sweet and
nice and even when she's telling me that
she doesn't find me sexually attractive
that she's doing it in the sweetest
possible way because she's just a sweet
sweet lady and when you're breaking down
she feels genuinely concerned for you
which is yes really funny there's a
plate of cookies there i believe yeah
yeah yeah she tried to give me cookies
about it but i wasn't you know i i
wasn't having that but uh yeah anyway i
love her performance i love how she
plays it and she all she always looked
like she could be your mom to me oh
really oh yeah yeah i i think there's a
i think i i see a resemblance there i
don't i don't know why but it and it's
just a question made the connection in
your mind and now it's real for you i
see it do you guy am i the only person
like i i think she looks like she could
be your mom
i feel like she looks like she could be
anyone's mom
nah
yeah maybe i don't know i mean america's
mom she's america's she's america's mom
have either of you guys ever dated like
a significantly older woman at any point
in your life
yes yeah what was the age discrepancy
between you and this uh 20 years oh wow
how old were you 20. uh i was 21 or 22.
and you did it was 42. oh wow how long
did you guys date we were
friends that would hang out from time to
time like it wasn't like it was like a
uh like a finite amount of time where we
were like oh we're dating yeah we would
hang out
go out and back yeah
have sex yeah just have fun and she was
really cool really fun do you feel taken
advantage of that they'll have you
really have you worked this out in
therapy like you know that's that's an
older person taking advantage of younger
person so do you well she was an agent
too which is even which is interesting
and i was a struggling actor
i wasn't concerned about the power
dynamic at the time no in retrospect um
no it was great it was really fun yeah
it was really fun and i remember you're
thinking like wow this is this is nuts
like but that's two years younger than
than i am i know
but at the time you know you're 20 i was
22 years old but yeah it was it was fun
she was actually she she showed me a
different new york city because i was
used to experiencing in new york city
the way that a 21 year old does or a 22
year old does and just irish she was
like taking tons of cigarettes she would
like take me out to restaurants and show
like broadway shows i saw a bunch of
broadway shows and that was really fun
yeah
that's that side of new york is fun i
it would have been fun to live in new
york uh i never lived there when i
actually had a little bit of cash to
spend i was just i was always so broke
like i would literally yeah if you went
into a nice restaurant you were either
applying for a job or trying to like
sneaky use their bathroom before they
kicked you out i mean i i would i would
go to this uh the these like my favorite
thing to eat in new york was burritos
because they were
relatively inexpensive and filled with
you know nutrition
or filled with sustenance calories i
should say
uh but i was so broke that i would
literally go buy a burrito
i would cook rice and beans at home
because they were cheap and like
vegetables and then i would go buy a
burrito i would bring it back to my
apartment i would cut it in half
and use half the burrito with my rice
and beans and like that would be my
lunch and then my dinner would be the
other half i couldn't i couldn't afford
to eat two burritos i couldn't have a
burrito for lunch and a burrito for
dinner i had to split it in half that's
how broke i was did you have sex with an
older lady i thought that's where that
was going no i was just you transitioned
i wanted to talk about burritos oh okay
all right
well this is what i was saying like this
is the difference between well he he
turned it around but he was legitimately
upset when he first came in
uh but like not in a funny way yeah
sometimes i'm upset and i'm all fired up
and like you were fired up about the
serial thing right after that
oh yeah when i yeah we were able there
was enough there were enough comedy
writers in the room oh no that's not at
all how that went down did he not
eventually come around no no no no
that's not at all how that works then we
have to save that for that episode
you were fired up about it you were
genuinely upset
you and i were my car was destroyed sure
you and i were amused by how upset he
was that's a fun that's a fun thing to
walk into right your car gets destroyed
your brand new car is the first time i'd
ever bought a nice new car in my entire
life i had a brand it was like a couple
months old
my car was destroyed and i come in upset
about it my friends are laughing at me
can we please clarify that yeah nothing
funny no one was hurt nothing's funny
about the fact that your car was
destroyed what's funny is that you were
eating cereal while driving your car
it's just an amusing thing yeah it was
also the way that we found it out it
would have been just as amusing if you
said i got a horrible car accident like
oh that's terrible you were like yeah i
was in the middle of crocheting this
beautiful sweater like wait you were
crocheting a sweater and driving a car
like like yes but that's not why i got
into the accident so and you were very
specifically upset about the fact that
the interior of your car was destroyed
not the exterior the exterior got pretty
banged up too but it was the interior
but that's fixable the interior if you
came in and you were like i got
rear-ended no one's laughing at you
right that's what happened i know but
what you then continued to tell the
story and as you were telling the story
you were like yeah and the [ __ ] whole
interior was ruined too and we were like
whoa
you must have gotten completely total
and you're like well no i mean like i
gotta get all the vents cleaned because
like all
and it was not your fault and we left
that part was not your fault and we left
it alone but then you were gone you were
out of town for a vacation or something
and it kind of came or it kind of came
back up and then we served rob and i
went down the rabbit hole and then
presented it to you after things had
settled and you were receptive of it but
i think if in that moment we said oh
that'd be a good episode it would not
have gone over well i don't know well
maybe yeah i can't i can't remember
exactly i do remember being very upset
about it sure i also remember i also
remember you're still upset about it no
no i mean i look i can get worked up
about just about anything
that's what you're looking for you can
get
[Music]
it uh rob do you i don't think
i don't feel as though you come in to
work hot does rob coming hot
no he he's a little bit more
professional you might be hot about some
like
work injustice like uh usually related
to like
you know on the corporate level um
it's a less caffeinated version of it
because you don't drink coffee anymore
you know because when i come in hot
there's caffeine put on top of it and
it's you know
it's intense yeah well i don't know i
yeah
i mean i get there from time to time i
guess maybe i don't start the day that
way usually yeah
but i get there i can get worked up i do
your kids drive you [ __ ] crap my kids
drive me crazy in the mornings
oh they drive me insane they're so loud
they're so loud i can't it's like i wake
up i walk downstairs and it's just
immediately like
just chaos yes chaos and fighting and
it's either
it's either uh screaming out of anger at
each other because they're in fighting
or it's like screaming because they're
playing they're playing annoying
characters that they play or it's the
youtube guy
that that guy should we call him out i
don't know i don't know his name sundy
sandy
hey buddy they love him hey buddy they
love him go [ __ ] yourself careful
careful he's their high piper but i'll
tell you he could probably get your kids
to do anything
well how about this don't put your kids
on youtube first thing in the morning
well no no no no no
they don't watch youtube in the morning
but we do we do allow them a certain
amount of screen time and they choose to
we're like look you get 45 minutes or
whatever it is to watch whatever it is
that you want and we think we're like
great like they're gonna watch a movie
you know or like like pizza and a movie
night was like great we'll all sit
around and we'll watch a movie together
but they want to watch
other people so play minecraft and do
youtube channels about it and it's you
don't want to be the old man who's
wagging his finger like hey back in my
day we used to play video games we
didn't watch people play video games
nevertheless
there's a few of them out there that are
particularly uh irritating well yes and
also like it is still
absolutely baffling to me uh that
someone instead of playing video games
would watch somebody else play video
games let me ask you this did you get
into a fist fight this weekend an actual
fist fight altercation what do you mean
i'm just asking no did you watch the
boxing match on saturday no um i wish i
had who played it was the heavyweight
championship of the world it was tyson
fury versus oh nobody watches that stuff
anymore oh it was massive and it was an
incredible fight but you watch boxing
but i used to you enjoy it it was my
favorite sport for a very long time and
i gave it up when i had kids because i
just didn't feel like i had the time to
keep up with it so i just kind of fell
off of it and but you do enjoy watching
other people
do something
right well it's it's an
endeavor meaning like you could go back
i would also say when we were kids and
you went over so i see what you're
saying i'm sorry you're making a
parallel between uh playing sports
versus watching somebody else playing
got it correct i understand yes yeah
yeah but also i didn't say when we were
kids you know you go over to your
buddy's house and and you'd be playing
nintendo and someone is playing the
level and it's like a one player game
and yeah you're sitting there watching
them play and if they were good enough
to to beat the whole damn thing you want
to see that you'd probably be in thrall
you'd be like oh [ __ ] like you're gonna
you're gonna fight everyone and mike
tyson and win like they're also like
learning things about how to navigate
and like i i get all that it's just that
it's just that the the the voice is very
specific i also just don't like the
manufactured enthusiasm he's like oh you
walked into a door yeah
i feel like a few people probably
stopped listening to the podcast but
that was good that's what that's what's
not about that that's what's annoying
about that that is literally what he
sounds have you watched this guy sunday
no no no no no no s-u-m-d-e-e look him
up he's the most [ __ ] annoying man on
the planet i'm not gonna [ __ ] him i'm
not gonna look him up you're [ __ ]
ruining my kids you [ __ ] guys do i
come in huh do i do i come out do i have
a hot streak i'm never it's not my thing
you're not really ever really aggressive
you're passive aggressive passive
aggressive a little bit my aggression
goes inward yeah no then it comes out
comes out just like it's like seeps out
it seems like pouring out yeah i can
tell when you're upset sure
but you're very rarely
you're not moody you're not moody you're
not a moody person you're upset it's
because of something very specific i i
i'm so i'm so overly affected by all
stimuli right so if something makes me
happy i can get very very happy if
something pisses me off i have trouble
letting it go and i see i'm seeing this
in my kids now too it's very disturbing
i'm like i don't know if i pass that on
to them as a learned behavior or if it's
just in their genes but like eisley
can't let let stuff go he just can't let
it go he gets angry and he just stays
angry for like 30 minutes
you're like dude we could
you gotta let it go you know what i mean
but i'm like i do the same [ __ ] i do the
same [ __ ] i don't know what that is i'm
like so reactive if you can figure out a
thing that works on him if you could let
charlie and i know so that you can use
it you can use it on you that'd be great
you guys like you do use my anger in the
show you use it all the time right
that's awesome i mean a lot of stuff
gets written because you know any one of
us is uh you know hung up about
something
seemingly insignificant or stupid or
something that really really bothers us
and we're like well that's an episode
and then we give it to dennis because
it's funny to watch you get angry yeah i
i i don't even watch anybody get angry
like then all our characters is funny
that's a just pure defense mechanism
guys like
because i get so worked up about [ __ ]
and i i realized at a certain point in
my life i was like well this is no fun
for anybody so so i i have to make it
funny
in order to be able to get away with
like ranting and raving i need your
rants
granting a joke so let me make it kind
of funny you know and uh now
uh i don't know if it's because it's
actually funny or if it's just because
like uh
uh
it's now i i don't know i don't know
what it is i don't know why it's funny
i don't know why it's funny because it
really is just me getting angry
let me even when i'm playing the
character it's like that i mean you guys
have seen me actually where i'm playing
the character and i get you know dennis
is ranting and raving about something
that i'm not even upset about as a
person but i'm i've done the scene so
many times i've done like five takes of
like yelling and screaming that it
literally puts me in a bad mood yes and
i'm i'm actually angry yes
you know you've released those hormones
into your body you know whatever yeah i
can't come i i get stuck you know it's
almost like i'm a real actor you know
what i mean it's almost like i'm so in
character
that uh you know i can't have trouble
dropping the character afterwards it's
almost as if
i'm as good of an actor as say christian
bale
you know it's almost like that it's
exactly like that
it's exactly like i'm as good an actor
as christian bale and yet you feel
trapped on this tv show which only makes
you angrier yeah it just doesn't work
why i don't know how you guys
are you christianity
huh are you christian i'm not actually
christian doing uh because that would be
ultimate performance christian bale
doing a glenn howerton and we didn't
even know no there is no glenn
harrington it's only it's a character of
christian bales yeah oh that'd be pretty
sweet
guys who would you want to play you in a
movie what actor would play you rob
steven seagal
[Laughter]
you know he can't stand up anymore right
yeah well you know i mean i don't know
by the way i don't know i can't say for
certain that he can't stand up i just
haven't seen him stand up in 10 years
yeah i don't think he can stand
you know god bless him you know he's
always shooting guns from the cg for
that they'll fix it they'll fix his legs
and posts yeah i'll fix him yeah i would
hope that i could get the part
you know um you know i know it's tough i
know casting out there is tough but boy
i feel like i can nail it well you i
don't know if you're a big enough box
office draw yeah to play yourself
yeah yeah maybe possibly this box office
is irrelevant now you know
everything's streaming spock's office
box office is irrelevant
box office [ __ ] oh you said spock's
office i don't know i don't [ __ ] know
i don't know i would like who's spock
dr spock
don't pick up on every consonant
so i'll pick up on every consonant
you're demanding perfection of
everyone's parking of everyone's words
oh look guys i'm fully aware of how
[ __ ] crazy i am it's entitlement man
oh 100 you're right you're absolutely
right charlie have i have we talked
about this did you just be yourself no
you're you're absolutely right you're i
i did i did kind of have that uh
revelation maybe a year ago
where i realized that most of the time
i'm angry
it what it all comes down to is
entitlement
as i feel entitled for everything to go
well and be smooth yeah and when it
doesn't go my way i get angry and it's
totally entitlement you're absolutely
right you weren't raised catholics so
you
you didn't you were somehow able to
avoid the self
hate and feeling of worthlessness that
no i always had a very
high
regard for myself yeah see that's a bad
thing yeah no no i don't know
periods where you want to really put put
yourself down constantly and then you
know and then you don't get so angry
about no you don't care yeah you'll go
into that parking garage and you're like
there's no available spaces i must have
done something wrong
you know and you won't get mad at
someone else you know
you'll just feel as though you weren't
worthy of having a good space oh i see
is that is that true of you rob as well
do you feel that
uh yeah i mean no i don't know if i feel
to that to that extent
yeah catholic catholicism is a strange
thing but it definitely puts you in it
sets you up for that yeah sure i i
rejected i don't know the mega church
that glenn was going to was setting him
up for success either was it no no no no
definitely you're a piece of [ __ ] in the
eyes of the church no matter whether
you're catholic or protestant but uh you
know you're we're all born sinners right
we're all born bad bad bad bad
and we need jesus to make us good good
good good so we can go to heaven heaven
heaven heaven heaven
money money and then do what and then
just kind of float around and yeah you
know like
living your mansion the idea of having
your consciousness for eternity
yeah is baffling like oh meg just
audibly sighed can you imagine yeah
you a man can you imagine um guys we did
it we did it it's not our best we we're
gonna keep going we got other [ __ ] to do
yeah
we got a show to cut together yep yeah
let's keep trucking guys let's keep
trucking let's do it okay park closer to
the column everybody all right all right
give it another go yeah tape measure it
be considerate be considerate